oh say can you see
we've been talking to people across the
US and across the world about what
America they want what are their hopes
were their dreams for the US for after
November the eighth today I want to talk
to Germans about what America they want
deserted us lands I'm y mi nuh nuh nuh
fighter mr. Trump revered as a loving
sister Amelia can you see invictus
analyzing asanas we often in Lander
Underland absent Iranian must build in a
zone and nan Austin the lsm Tish the
official open official photos or whoever
Jesus democratic-led this newest island
of conservatism future and protesters
also blind
I want an America where people can be
happy being who they are and with who
they love what America I want I want
America to help Muslim on Kovic work i
won an America where every citizen feels
proud to be part of a democracy the
island America who will provide peace
not war
one by one
competent authority
deeper voice while polemical is and when
they officially marked on
about home Hilary but it ended as the
only stock artists inspire bernasconi
the Amazon a mountain marathon runner
yeah yes Aisha lagoons try out a 10 X 10
different entrante hadiqa as a ver yet
sphere for Trump estate the internet
laws yeah but their felonious state
facility cooling
you